one of the stars of the u.s. Ryder Cup
team bringing home the cup first time
since 2008 he's Patrick Reed had that
showdown with Rory McIlroy and Patrick
joins us good morning Patrick how are
you I'm pretty good I got to bed at a
reasonable time I don't know about you
4:30 is that reasonable that sounds
pretty good it's more sleep than I
thought you were going to get yeah you
know it was a it was a great night you
know all the celebrations from you know
finally bringing that cub back home and
you know it was a it was awesome and to
be around all the guys last night seeing
how much it really meant to all of us it
was it was really neat and really cool
experience what's your favorite story
from that moment that celebration that
you'll tell your kids you know I think
the biggest thing is uh you know we went
around the guys went over and we took
the trophy over and you know it's just
the guys in the room just the just
players and the the cabins assistant
captains and you know it went around and
you know every one of us we used the
might of the trophy as a mic and so
every player would have to hold the
trophy I'll have to say something that
you know whether they're thankful for
something that they you know really
appreciate something that happened this
week and you know it was really cool
just to hear all the guys reflect on
different things and you know just
getting closer even closer as a team and
you know by the time we got done with
that we come out and you know the
European guys they're over here and
we're all kind of hanging out in the
same room have you know having a good
time and you know it just shows not only
the um how much tournament meant to us
but also you know how the friendships
have bonded not just between our team
but both teams whose bar tab was bigger
the US or the Europeans I have no idea I
didn't actually didn't have anything to
drink last night which was shocking no I
made a mistake of Presidents Cup two
now to have a good time with all the
guys is the next day like this morning
and the next day I
I could barely pack I had a headache I
didn't know you know I'm a lightweight
as it is I mean yeah I'm just like you
know guys I'm not doing it this week
Patrick you sounds I didn't you sound
like this without drinking yeah because
I lost my voice but yelling for my team
and everything all week you know I mean
the sad thing is my voice has actually
gotten better since yesterday and the
day before I mean before I just sound
like a broken record if people didn't
see the front nine with you and roaring
how would you sum that up yesterday the
front line
yeah well the first two I mean I mean
for me yeah let's say epic you know to
go out and play the way we did you know
first a little shaky on both of us I
mean I I don't it left and then after
that you know I'm making that 20 20 25
footer up over the ridge to have the
whole one just kind of set the tone yeah
you know the crowd got right in it and
he birdied three they made five drivable
and I go ahead and make Eagle and heat
birdies then you know topping birdies on
six topping birdies on seven and get to
eight and he makes a putt from 70 feet
and then me topping it from 25 feet I
mean it was just a all out just epic
round fun night of golf I mean you
couldn't if you're going to say that I
was gonna be holes like 2 3 4 5 under
par through 8 and then be all square I'm
sayin nuts you know there'd be no way I
mean I would think for sure especially
in singles match we don't have a
teammate that if I be to maybe I'm you
know worse to up and you know just shows
how how solid golfers are here I'm
playing these events and how yet you
have to step up and you know do your job
and play some good golf
he's Patrick Reed the victorious u.s.
Ryder Cup team joining us Dan Patrick
show but you guys played to the crowd
and but explained to me
it's a it's not I don't know if it's
taunting its it there's a rivalry you're
trying to win it's a gentleman sport
like there's so much involved in that
Patrick I was trying to figure out you
and Rory the relationship during the
round itself can you describe that yeah
you know just emotional high you know
going out especially when you're that
first match out on Sunday you need to go
out and win that match you know cuz all
the momentum to the team that wins that
match and you know I took Adam Ellie hey
you know you we know they're gonna
front-load because they need you off the
hot start I told captain I want to go
first you know put me first but Jordan
second mm and you know with him be you
know trust me me going out put me for us
to go in that point yeah I figured that
Rory had to be you know first or second
out and they put their best guy out o
this week against myself and to go out
there and play play with Rory
I knew that you're going to make birdies
and he was getting the crowd all going
for the first two days and I was getting
the cargo on my matches so I knew it was
just gonna be it all out just you know
go for broke and you know attack mode on
both sides you know Rory Rory and I it
was more on kind of a show you know I
would taunt him a little bit try get in
his head he would taunt right back to me
try get in mine but if you also noticed
every every time we did it when we were
walking off the greens or anything in
between the holes there were thumbs up
so there were smiles or were you know
fists palms I mean there was everything
you know the guy a guy and I we just
blew out had some fun and you know we
had a blast and even after the round and
drop the round we're talking about I
we're gonna see each other again we're
gonna play all that stuff so you know
it's good to see cuz we're out there and
yeah we're bantering back and forth and
trying to get the crowd going but also
at the same time you know our
friendships that we have with these guys
is
is way larger than you know a shush or a
finger white or a bow or you know stuff
like that it's just you know this is all
fun and games how much fun would the
tour be if it was that kind of
atmosphere
whoo it would be amazing I would
absolutely love it
you know but you wouldn't be able to
play 35 weeks a year you know I'm
exhausted on all night last night and
when I sat down right at media after
after around and we're all sitting up
there and my calves and my feet were
just dropping and they they haven't
gotten any better I cannot wait to you
know hopefully stay in bed for like 24
hours or something like that just try to
get them to recoup because it's a lot of
golf you know captain put us out Jordan
I out five five matches and three days
so you know it was a lot of golf well
you know we stepped out and did what we
needed to do and you know it's
definitely worth the pain and suffering
afterwards good to visit with you it was
a lot of fun a lot of fun to watch the
entire weekend Patrick congratulations
thank God the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience